يتبارى سكان خاركيف لإيجاد
مأوى بينما يتكشف هجوم روسيا الوحشي
عن مشاهد عميقة تحت الأرض
تذكرنا بالحرب العالمية الثانية
، الصدمة التي غرقت للتو في أن ما كان
لا يمكن تخيله أصبح الآن حقيقة
كما تخبرنا داريا البالغة من العمر 36 عامًا أنك
تستيقظ في واقع جديد تمامًا في الخامسة صباحًا و
تكتشف أن العالم لم يعد
المكان الآمن الذي تتخيله أننا
بلد مستقل في أوكرانيا
ولسنا تمامًا مثل الروس
ولا نريد أن نكون جزءًا من روسيا أو أي
دولة أخرى ،
لقد أصبح الأمر عاطفيًا جدًا حقًا
وأنا  لا أصدق أنه حدث
بالأمس حقًا ، لقد كانت مجرد
محطة مترو عادية مليئة بالأشخاص الذين يذهبون
إلى العمل ومنهم اليوم ، فقد أصبح
ملجأً بحكم الواقع للقنابل وهناك
مئات ومئات الأشخاص الذين
نزلوا في هذا المكان خائفين
على حياتهم و  غير متأكد مما
سيحمله المستقبل والشيء الذي تسمعه
مرارًا وتكرارًا من الناس
هو أين يمكننا أن نذهب وأين من الآمن
الآن الذهاب في أوكرانيا وأريد  لنكون واضحين
بشأن شيء ما هذه ليست مدينة خط المواجهة
في حرب أوكرانيا التي استمرت ثماني سنوات مع
روسيا ، فهذه مدينة مزدهرة تضم
1.4 مليون شخص لم يسبق لهم
تجربة أي شيء من هذا القبيل في
حياتهم كلها ، والآن
يُجبرون على التخييم حرفياً خارجها.
مع عائلاتهم حيواناتهم الأليفة
وأحبائهم أخذوا كل ما في وسعهم من
منازلهم وأحضروه إلى هنا
ولا يعرفون ما هو التالي بالنسبة
لهم لا يعرفون كيف ستبدو أوكرانيا الجديدة
والمكان الذي
سيكونون فيه  إن
الكثير من الأمور التي نتعامل معها قد تغلبنا عليها
للتحدث ، أطلب منهم
أنهم متوترون للغاية ،
انظروا إلى الموقف من حولك ،
تقول هذه المرأة إنه
لا يوجد شك هنا حول من
المسؤول عن هذا الصراع ،
لكن القليل منهم يفهم السبب ،
لذا فهو مثير للاهتمام ، لقد سألت للتو
ما رأيهم في الرئيس بوتين ، هل
يعتقدون أنه مجنون؟ قالوا إنه ليس
مجنونًا ، إنه مريض ،
إنه مريض ،
نريد فقط أن نعيش بسلام ،
وآمل فقط
أن يرى بعض الناس في روسيا  يقف
فقط
ضد القدم والجدار
نداء بسيط للرحمة التي لم تسقط حتى الآن
على آذان صماء.